what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan sockin we are now
going to be talking about conscious
reality creators we have the founders of
conscious reality creator joining us on
the show we have Elizabeth Jackson we
have Rick Parris we have grace Paris
we have maverick Paris and we have
Andrew Thompson hello hello thank you
for coming on the show I'm so pumped I'm
so comfy the follow-up from our first
episode with Rick and we actually did a
deeper cut with Ricky immediately
episode it was so good so you guys can
find those links in the bio below also
for those that don't know conscious
reality creator is a process to change
your paradigm to become self determined
and self authored and you can find the
conscious reality creator calm link in
the bio as well as their YouTube channel
which has great content on and going
check it out subscribe check out those
videos alright let's start things off by
talking about
conscious reality creator from the
perspective of set theory what is set
theory i reck'n take that away well set
theory is the idea that in order for you
to have the complete understanding set
you have to get outside set and so the
way out sometimes I explain that is
you're watching a football game to the
stadium and say the quarterback throws a
pass and alignment barely touches it and
then it goes to middle linebacker he
catches interception almost nobody on
the field knows which
happen they just know everybody's
running the other way now they don't
realize that it was the linemen who
tapped it that went here that went there
right so in the stands you'll see all of
that you'll be able to see everything
that transpires on the field so in order
free for you to understand descent
you've got to be able to see the whole
thing as it operates and be separate
from that set really because what he's
been teaching and what he taught us was
how to get out from paradigm we're
currently in which I think a lot of
people can recognize is coming apart and
does it feel really good right there's
like a paradigm shift occurring so to
like understand this that you have to
leave this that let's kind of describe
it to me just from that simple idea but
most people are trying to put it another
way people are trying to fix the problem
within the system you can't be in the
system to fix the problem leaving that
system into a new system completely
right and a set maybe you can just
describe a little more sets paradigm
right you have a paradigm as a set or I
said this is a set right now we're gonna
set right we're all sharing an
experience but people outside the set
I've been watching how they're related
oh and Rick said that Elizabeth didn't
really like it I may not right it's like
so when you're outside the set you've
got a capacity to see the whole thing
so yeah since I died like a lot of
people will because they're not used to
speaking to that they'll be like oh well
that's your opinion I'll say actually
it's not an opinion for me it's an
experience I've already left this set
put myself back into a new set and so I
have an experience of dying and
understand
conscious how reality is operating and
I'm just coming back and sharing that
but it's not an opinion I didn't read a
book about dying and somebody told me
and now I'm share it's an experience and
most people have learned everything from
an opinion of another person that you
align with but that person rarely had
the experience either I mean how many
people met Buddha or Jesus and they're
following a set there which is really an
opinion of someone else I'm falling I'm
not so far third I'm not self determined
in that set okay so would it be fair to
say that the idea of set theories to
take a third-person perspective on the
world and on your life it's an elevated
perspective in a sense because of now I
see what's going up like you now when
you're healing the childhood within you
you're not in that setting now that says
influencing this set because I haven't
really moved out of it my child is very
present in my daily life once you
understand a new your child of you your
child is now healed existing in a set
that's not influencing this set but to
connect with what you're saying you are
taking the observer right the
third-person but it's also first-person
it's complex because you have to feel
what the child film right to get in
touch to get intimate with what it is
you're trying to heal you got to go and
do it and feel it
so it's both you're looking at it so
that you're not getting lost in it but
you're also in it feeling it at the same
time so it's actually done two positions
okay I like that so it's both this
higher elevated perspective on your life
and being conscious creating your future
life that you want but also being able
to ground yourself in the feeling the
feelings the important part you got to
be able to feel if you're gonna go to
heal anything and touch anything
they were change anything in your life
you have to feel and the only way to do
that is to get into it and feeling this
is something Rick has taught me hugely
because most of us I think numb out
because the certain said that we're in
is a set of struggle it hurts and so to
make it through that set we got a numb
out we gotta stop feeling I mean that's
move past my brief rant reframing all
the time trying to stay away from the
things that bother me try and separate
from the things that bother me
what did you do if you don't separate
yourself from the things that how do you
approach the things that do bother you
or the things that don't serve us you
bond to them appropriate howdy what is
responding well you have to give me an
example and then I can tell you right
because I can't work no we could use the
example that you just want good so like
I had an extra roommate that was kind of
like threatening some law issues or
whatever so let's say if I was in the
old set I would probably just be super
pissed off that I had another crazy
roommate and oh my god why is this
happening to me cuz most people go into
victim and blade because that's the old
paradigm but he's taught me how to do it
from the new paradigm so this first
thing with what are you feeling okay
you're feeling anger okay where's that
coming from
you were a martyr so now you're
punishing so it's like that's how you
break it down so if you want to describe
that's how what right whatever you're
feeling see reality is the end of the
equation the reality begins inside
subjectively and that shows me
objectively what it is that I am doing
inside so what happens is when you shift
something from the inside there's going
to be a shift on the outside so you have
to respond to that like if it this
situation goes down it makes me angry
that's what mostly that's making me
angry no you're actually angry and I'm
creating a situation in order to feel
the things that I haven't been feeling
that's why like I clean up road-rage a
lot of people like very calm rational
people and they get in the car traffic
time and they're screaming and everyone
and flipping people off and driving like
a me because I don't know where else
expressed my anger but right here in the
car and this is
everybody's pissing me off in traffic
the way they're drunk it's really
because you're mad all day and now I
need to get rid of some of this so my
pressure but you're creating that people
are bothering you because you're
bothered underneath when you release
that there's no reason to be mad anymore
so back to your Steven the how do you
respond appropriately it's like that so
then the first step would be responding
is figuring out what you're creating
figuring out know yourself you're
authoring why I have an example you have
a you have a goal for your future in one
of the ones you've talked to me about is
filling a stadium with the talk right
something like that so that's one yeah
yeah if that's your image for the future
that's what you're going for you've
created that in your imagination what
feelings come to you when you create
that space success before euphoria
abundance an hour man you know a bunch
of quality feeling transformation of 55
I give all the same time so that's your
goal you're now moving towards that goal
on the way to that goal you've run into
a situation where someone triggers you
and now you have a negative feeling and
it's a feeling of not enough righteous I
hit a barrier and my success maybe it
was trying to get subscribers for your
channel you didn't get to the place
where you wanted to by the time you
wanted to and you feel limited as soon
as you feel limited you know that's not
the new set the new set is where I'm
headed the new set is the the place that
I've created in my imagination and I
know all the feelings that go with that
news that's your resource yeah so the
the limited feeling you know this is
from my past I'm living in my past right
now with this feeling coming up and as
soon as you feel that limitation it
doesn't feel good it's very easy to
recognize now that you're headed towards
those quality feeling interesting so
baby so so in a sense the the the set
that we're trying to consciously create
is this future of whatever we want to
unleash our gifts into the world
whatever you want yeah whatever that
want is and then all of the all of these
like feelings of lack or anger or all
those other things to be able to kind of
see that as just not serving us and it's
it's serving their baby but here was
some innovation in in motivating us
towards that future that we now know
it's like it's acting a suffering for us
to do it if you have a belief that no
pain no gain you know everything like
business is hard and it takes a couple
years to make money right yeah that's a
sin I'm creating so now you agree with
this set and you take two or three years
see the same thing like if you say that
makes me before thinking about a film
stadium you still want to know where's
that euphoric feeling come because it
might may be a lesson to me feeling like
I'll be totally like good enough when
that happens
so nobody value yeah then I will feel my
value rather than feeling it now see so
what will happen is you may not get to
that event because it's not coming from
the adult you it's coming from an
adolescent lesser part of you so you're
you're trying to go after a goal that's
not even in your best interest it's in a
lesser part of yours best interest so
there's not a lot of energy going to it
that's positive it's really making a
compensation for something I didn't get
in another time so we're consciously
looking at the set and knowing what is
these driving forces of our ancestors of
our childhood of and so we're conscious
of looking at our timeline and
consciously looking at our future taking
this this higher elevated perspective on
that yeah but you don't have to look at
all that meaning once you've chosen your
future the only only the stuff that
shows up is gonna be between you and
your future you don't have to go back
into all the gunk oh you want your
present in the future for the division
I'm gonna hit resistance it's on the way
those are the pieces I need to get there
and it's not
like teach you a lesson it's like if you
decide to go for more which most people
are unless you're really stuck which
people are which was why they keep
hitting the same wall once you decide
like us that we're going forward we know
anything we hit it's not there to teach
us how our teachers it's literally just
to show you this isn't the way of over
there this it's just like when I have
all my issues popping up with people I
call Rick person's like what is this
because I know this is the obstacle
that's here in front of my future me I'm
trying to go to future me and this is
just show me oh yeah I still got some
like residents going on with passes and
my higher self is showing me like this
is it right now this is the one blockage
so once I clear that I'm gonna have
resistance for a while it's whenever the
resistance comes it's like no I'm still
living out a past well it's a belief
from your past so like most of us have a
belief that for instance you're at the
dinner table and your parents you know
you wanted to get up and not finish your
meal and they said oh you're not going
to be able to have dessert unless you
finish what you eat so it was either
finish what you eat or I'll punish you
if you do what I say you'll get the
reward yo right there is after you do
exactly so right there you have a belief
set that I have to if I do something
wrong I have to go through punishment in
order to get back to my pleasure back to
what's good right so a lot of us have
that set in our lives and so as we're
going for what we want that can show up
you punish yourself because you no
longer have a parent over you as you're
grown up now you're the one punishing
yourself and you start just creating
over yeah you create hardships in your
life to punish you and then if you fail
you may punish it off [ __ ] I'm a [ __ ]
idiot that's all just going right back
to that old thing because you're going
through a set is like you got to punish
myself so that I can get back to feeling
good but in order to get there I got to
go through this pain and so once you
recognize those things it's easy and
Rick teaches it it's a process you just
go in and you can just
those beliefs and then you don't even
have to worry about those processes
anymore because I think that the old
satin I think is important to say people
are not going through it they're not
understanding how I'm responsible for
creating this what is this telling me
about me out of a sense of love it's
because you love yourself you're trying
to grow it's all in love it's not here
to look I have the same loser boyfriend
again no it's like something in me is
trying to show me like this is what
you're supposed to understand about
yourself to go where you want to go and
so it's like in the past that you get
what you don't like like oh there's this
thing I don't like I don't like this
room a don't like this problem and so
then you just omit yourself from it
physically so that's why I just keep
keep stirring up keep showing up it's
not because you're not like better or
it's because you don't understand you
didn't get that information once you
understand the information and you could
break it down holistically
then you could move forward and not have
to repeat okay let me see you do this so
yeah there's we do have an elevated
perspective on our our ancestors and our
and our childhood and our present and
our future we have elevated perspective
elevated perspective on that when we're
mostly focused on the present to the
future and then we I I still see these
things that happen on that path like
blockages that you can remove these
limiting beliefs and things like that
that can be removed but like you guys
were indicating there's so many of these
experiences that come in to be like hey
like are you ready to remove that
blockage or you just gonna like repeat
the same thing over and over again as
they're gonna be a repairing they're
going to be a growth process here and so
but why would that not be like like a
lesson or a challenge for you to like
rise to the occasion and the difference
is it's not as no pain no gain it's not
a lesson like a lesson is like a noble
eyes thing that is like oh I hadn't you
know in my passive I struggled with drug
addiction I hadn't gone
drugs money I need to tell the script I
haven't gone to that drug addiction I
wouldn't have been where I am but can't
the lesson be framed in a way that gosh
that was such a powerful lesson yeah is
a set or yeah nonetheless gonna be
viewed was just a mirror it's just a
choice you made at some point that's all
the way she made but what doesn't serve
you in him but we can't view it
positively tiller that's a refresh you I
get what you're saying
you can view it positively but no no
belies don't know yeah I had breast
cancer and she had wonderful and she
really believed that had I not gone
through this experience and had one of
my breasts removed that I wouldn't be
where I was today but that was the best
experience of my life it was absolutely
not that was not the best experience for
you you have to have to learn how to get
your you didn't need to do that to learn
that you that's you turned it into that
experience after but you didn't have to
do that at all if you would have stopped
early interestings are just not noble
wise things learn yeah and have a
beautiful grow through on streets but
not noble eyes yet something that is
like you know a horrific car accident or
whatever yeah the only thing that
couldn't really Eliza get out because
they think it took that for me to get it
yeah it's like that's the quote about
the roots needing to reach down to hell
in order for the fly to the heavens it's
it's only a belief that was set so this
woman who had this this you know had a
breast removed she had some sort of
belief that she has to struggle to get
response or something right
like I'm gonna get crucified on a cross
you can bleed it out forget you know
anything think about it you get what I
want
maybe that's Noble it's like two
somebodies that yes even the story you
just gave about how you're gonna finish
what's left on your plate yeah that's
like such a snob or such a great lesson
the parents taught us right into play
and they're just doing that cuz nobody
else did it to them somebody but then
nobody you know what why am i doing that
yeah why do I need to finish everything
on my plate before I move on why do I
need to do my homework before I get
through what's up why are we setting up
a set like that it is apparently the
future creates the present and so if you
don't know that the only resource you
have is the past and you keep alluding
the past and the important thing to note
on that with the nobles ation is
mobilization is an emotional thing and
so you give it now significance and if
you're giving more significance to your
past and you're giving emotional
significance to where you're headed
guess what your results are gonna be
from your past interesting so then
there's another major aspect to this
which is the noble ization of these past
experiences kind of keep us in that in
this like a duration of those past
experiences rather than always linking
up with the present to the future and
linking up to the future that I'm
creating and the rest you know that
didn't lessen the present if you watch
like some of these videos there's like a
couple of hours that I've seen and it
always like it just always hits my heart
so much because I studied with him and
he became
family like this is so amazing you know
but one of the things you say in all the
videos I want you to learn their joy not
great you know like you have to take
that for more than just a statement it's
true like most people learn through
suffering that's what brought me to them
I was in the worst year of depression
for over a year and I was also tempted
to be like well I'm so glad it happen
because it brought me to you
of course I'm glad it happened because
it did bring me to them but he's very
always pointing out but that's the way
you chose it from knocks at you you know
you ever have to have your next growth
spurt by being in a hole for a year like
that's terrible I want to grow now
through joy and happiness what would it
be would that how would that look like
how would a child like maverick how a
maverick be able to grow through joy and
not like an experience of suffering
right now he's unconsciously thinking
all this conversation he's learning this
like I said my parents were throwing
[ __ ] and screaming and choking each
other and hitting each other and he's
never even seen that kind of experience
before he learns language and before
verbally you know he's listening to all
these things he may not be able to piece
it together but he's getting the
resonance he's getting the vibration of
people that are living in a different
experience I can probably I know this
kid's gonna be a different kind of human
being not doing anything else than
making sure that he's unconditionally
loved so the fact that you are at peace
you are unconditionally loving him as a
family and then they're like throwing
things around and yeah that kind of
stuff okay so you're you're moving like
this over you're moving this Overton
Window more towards progress towards
enlightenment or ethical and moral
righteousness that type of stuff so that
way we don't have to relive the same
sufferings of our past so then the
paradigm seems as though it's shifting
like almost then is it completely away
from this need to noble eye suffering
and rather in a way to noble eyes joy
like I'm like what is my what is that
ventures that I'm gonna create business
and that free right thread about sitting
on that okay okay
happiness is a fulfillment of your needs
a roof flat water food I have friends
belong to them
that's that creates happiness it also
creates an addictive pattern because now
if I don't have those things I'm not
happy so the growth of joy I have to
figure out what my preferences are and
since that changes moment to moment day
to day you're not living in the past
when you choose a preference because
when you fulfill a preference you're
enjoying your experience now I'm having
it exactly the way I wanted it excites
me and it's fun and I'm enjoying it and
when you're doing something it's obvious
when you're like I'm so into that's
awesome and so you're fulfilling a
preference now you're in the growth
you're in growth mode I'm enjoying my
experience I'm living fully in the
moment at peace
simultaneously joy and peace you want
that joy peace and so you must be
choosing preferences so you have to be
conscious you cannot just get into an
addictive patterns what makes me happy
now I'm in a pattern that has been
real-time according to Who I am in real
time because moment to moment your
preference has changed so you have to be
conscious of what you're doing and we're
constantly adjusting and tuning their
preferences based on the future we want
yes right and that's why when you go for
the future we talk about you let go of
that form you know your goal may be this
the stadium but that's just to generate
the function so what does that mean what
is this so so I'm going to feeling yeah
as you're going for the for the goal of
your future you're staying with the
quality feelings you got once you went
to imagination
Saida Delgado imagine all these people
in the stadium we're all around
everybody so joyful and you start
getting all these great feelings now
that I'm going for it I keep going off
those feelings right as soon as
something else negative comes up that I
know obviously I can go through that
from the past I clear it and I get back
on track but you're not hanging on to
the form of it meaning on your path
there your goal could shift you could
turn into something else right you see
you're always like building a leading
youth X about half because it's madness
it's preferences along the way but so
then what is what is the that future
that we envision that's the future your
great emotions under what imagining is
the finish the function okay so I'm
gonna feel you okay all right so the
function is this future that I wanted
yes the functions of future that we want
agree in the form is the process begin
no no no no well so the future is the
form of formation and the function is
how you get together and so when we
first started the first month it was
like let's make a dream and sound like
well I don't know I feel so good right
now what did I give up a white man I
guess good that just seems like my
default so I decided function boyfriend
you know like boyfriend before so then I
was like okay imagine love and my future
with a partner and then within days I'd
say all the sudden not became like so
not even my issue what is gonna lick two
is now all the time I am like totally
after like money and independence and
freedom through like business and all
its kind of stuff yeah so that was the
function the form would like boy friend
or lover partner but I didn't stay
attached now because I kept following
the function and then I realized that
must have been linked because really it
was empowerment that I was going I'm
just thinking that having a boyfriend
was gonna
her to have a better life to have a more
secure life all these things that
getting the right man does free but if I
was attached to the forum I'd probably
be like lumen people but it's that I'm
like one boyfriend I have the function
now because the function was power and
love for myself and of course like
before yeah yeah and that's another
thing I realized what I really wanted
was intimacy maybe not a partner and
like they've become my family so I have
that yeah okay so we okay so we have we
have a form that is this future that
we're see that we're at that is our gift
that we want to bring to the world and
then the function we stay very flexible
to the way that we're going to get
dude that the reality is gonna get
created to get to them because it's a
dream it exists on the edge of your
personal boundaries right because let's
say I'm a dreamed of this fifty thousand
thing I went fifty thousand people in a
stadium filled up that's my dream that's
this well you're not really imagining
millions
you're imagining fifty thousand because
I really can't comprehend millions but
when I get to be thousand that may very
well be on the country had millions
right so that's that's the edge of your
dream so if I go after that I'm gonna be
confronted with everything that blocks
me on my way of having this thing
because I'm already pushing the
boundaries what I see as possible so if
you pick something that's a dream you're
gonna hit your limitations immediately
because you're knocking on the very
essence of my boundary what do you
choose us form if not then some sort of
an aspiration or you said not a dream
well no no dream is any dream and all
will do but any dream you pick is the
edge of where I can see into that was I
exist
misty thousand versus one mil really
yeah eight billion people all
consciously cry their own listing
expressions forward could be like
Google's gonna be very far out all I
ever do is one if you can do with one
then you move it
then you then you move out and you're
building a real base now because I'm
close intimate with each can each part
of this pyramid okay question in terms
of the form do you have like a like a
step one form a step ten form step 100
form like welcome back 10,000 so I have
an example of this so when you're doing
your future imagination you imagine it
like you're out on the sea and you're on
a boat and you're actually literally
throwing out anchors to where you're
headed mmm so now you're being pulled
mm-hmm more direct right and so you
started with your maybe it's a five-year
plans five years out and you got your
goal when I write there right so you
throw out that first anchor now you're
like pulling yourself towards it
emotionally right you're following the
emotion that's taking you there like a
magnet yes but now you go maybe for
years and now you do backtrack from
where you started and start coming out
more anchors more anchors and more
anchors what you're doing is you're
creating now so much more significance
in your future the pathway to get there
is gonna be so much easier whereas if
you're trying to propel yourself through
the water and a storm comes or something
shows up that's in your way it's easier
to lose track but you got these Amiens
now that you're just rolling on anything
shows up it's so much easier to stay
right on track sounds more like a
harpoon well looks like you're able to
throw it out
throwing a hook as I listen I like this
so much when you own to your imagination
what's the first thing that you can ask
here is you have to question what do I
want
so right there you just opened a space
okay and this is a magnetic space yes
it's it's feminine in nature it's like a
womb it just opened up and it's waiting
to be filled and you're filling it now
with all the imagination that you want
to fill that space with emotionally
you're super charging it vibrationally
with everything that you want and so now
it's a very supercharged magnet that's
just polling you right or die's it right
where do you decide that space the more
emotions you're putting into it the more
it's like a song like for instance a
550,000 well now I better understand how
many stadiums carry 50,000 people what
city would it be in the weather be like
you see you've got a key if you're not
just the other that's my goal
there's not enough detail to get
significance there it's like okay so I
like the this point that this is like a
wound to film have it your conscious
reality what's the worst and you do have
the detail like you were listening to it
which then makes it more more what
happens is when you have vision though
and you're in the more real way I'm
doing it you're imagine this is a
feedback mechanism electrically coming
back through my brains med the measuring
devices the more real is in your brain
when you're in the meditation it's more
real you're bringing the more real into
an illusion when you're meditating and
imagining and like if you like now he's
a new magical I bet you salivate because
your body doesn't know that's not coming
yeah right so that's what you're doing
you're getting yourself to get in but
you see that's people now are like how
do I get there one of the steps you
don't need to worry about the steps
their dog video like the desire for it
is going to tell you who do I need to be
to become that now it's gonna tell you
what things to happen unless you don't
go after it it's a fantasy now if I'm
not taking action it's fantasy
so there's actually also this is a lot
is I want to also mention like on a on a
science level we've now been doing map
maps of neural
activity while people do things like
just imagine themselves playing the
shooting the basketball and it's the
same as when they're actually going in
Schad it's actually even better yeah
because it's when you map down as the
feeling and then the body movements go
from the feeling you just get into
thrill of the thing you don't have to
imagine the subconscious already saw you
do it knows what you're doing just throw
the ball you're actually just bringing
that illusion into the real there's
nothing to do I've already imagined it
if tonight believed in myself when I
trust myself when I trust the way that I
do it just throw the ball soon so
whether it's gonna go in before these
interviews when we do this this
conscious connection of like we're gonna
rock this interview we're so pumped
we're literally manifesting our success
on our ability to interplay with each
other successfully on the program before
we can start are you actually feeling
you're gonna fail so you can't just be
busy morning you got to legitimately
[ __ ] believe you're gonna do it but
feel it whatever feelings missing like
if I'm feeling I really could do it
instead of my money oh you gotta go okay
surprise I believe yeah well that's
because there's a belief in there that
you need to unplug so that's not
influencing me anymore not only I don't
care what you say I don't care what you
say I'm dragging that [ __ ] everywhere
while I'm trying to be successful just
unplug that and release that and then
it's much easier so when you do it's
like but you got to know how to do it
when you set out your future when you
sell out your imagination that's
actually a great time to process because
once you start doing that and you start
growing it right and you're imagining
this stadium and then you see certain
individuals and now starts getting
personal if you see a hero of yours
right there in the front row looking at
you and then all of a sudden a fear
crops up boom that's something you could
process like oh what's that fear what's
that limitations now you can process
that now before I even start moving
towards over right it's already on right
now let me do it now if you
getting mad be mad now don't be like
that because you just dropped your
little thing you didn't even go through
the thing that came up that's limiting
me on my path I'll just stop and think
about this later and go home and reefer
figure out what I did no no no you stay
right now and you deal I'm frickin
pissed I don't have to beat anybody up
with my anger but I'm angry about what's
going on right now and I need to express
that so it's not being stuffed back into
my unconscious and polluting what I'm
trying to do from here because you'll be
running off of that function we just
have Liz never on a shoot it was
stressful we were both kind of
frustrated but I was starting to lose it
right because I was just I had anger
I was losing my sturdiness on where it
was and Lizbeth recognized it she pulled
me outside let's take a break and she
had me express my feelings right so I
told her I'm feeling anger I'm feeling
upset right now and I just like you know
this is all too much so then I took a
second to go around the corner I just
went around the corner crops by
advantage of fun [ __ ] girl I
started yelling like anything that was
coming up that needed to be said from my
angry adolescent my angry hurt child
anything it doesn't matter meaning I'm
not gonna judge myself what'd I say [ __ ]
that [ __ ] people you know what I
mean like let it out yeah and so I said
that I just vented it vented it got it
out and as soon as it was out then I was
cool when I was cleared and I was able
to now get right back on track like okay
now I know the feelings that I'm moving
back also took your authority back yes
like you're in charge of your life and
how many people has an adult heart they
might say like I'm in charge but are you
in charge like Dennis is this the law
says that the religion says that a lot
of people are not actually in charge of
their life and so you have to become
they're in charge of my baggage right
I'm in charge of all my baggage but
another charge of all of it you are all
that baggage are places that you haven't
dealt with
at certain times and so since you can't
separate from them they are tainting
everything I'm trying to do from here
and if they get enough of that that
would completely inhibit you from being
successful but it's just because I
haven't dealt with all the way that I
deal with life is not appropriate I have
to find a new way to deal with life
separate from this but not because I
hate it because it's heal complete than
total ownership 100 percent hundred
percent and then let's use can we is
there by chance a single word or phrase
that we could use regarding the is it
healing or integration or what is it
really really 100 percent that's okay
yes so okay this is great the phrase we
create a reality 100 percent and now
let's look at those two sides that we
were talking about and we're not going
to spend too much time in the past side
like we were talking about but in that
past side is it healing is an
integration you were talking about the
baggage what is the word or the phrase
regarding that that people can applies
the past it's just the CI the past
doesn't exist well I ask you the problem
you have to imagine and tell me what I
don't have to imagine back was yeah
because that's your mind going back to a
pattern it's not real either
you've made it significant you've made
it be this stumbling point you've made
it something that defined me and you you
don't know how to get rid of it's a
pattern so it's a patty or something
harder yes and so if we view the past as
a pattern and then what we have now is
the presence of the future the future is
a source of all healing if a person
loses touch with the future that they
could beat the cancer they could beat
where they'll die it's because they're
both people died most because they don't
know how to imagine a future I'm 90 I
could be dead tomorrow I don't imagine a
future so you just run that a room and
you die it's not because of anything
else I just don't know how this operates
and I'm not really operating within it
love thermodyne
you're a state of decline that's not
true that is an incorrect law you're in
a state of change like the question of
how do you describe this would also be
true to say it's not separating anyone
yes almost everything you go back to
because like everything I need to have
but like you're separating from yourself
so that's what you have to identify what
am i separating from why I might
separating it from now I need to forgive
myself what I've done to myself and
created all this and then close the loop
by not separating because it's all you
right it's all you so you have to stop
you forget you cannot make it to be
judge something and change it at the
same time negative judgment separates
you from experience I'm not comfortable
I don't like those people no you cannot
do anything to change that so what do
you keep a neutral or you own it if you
really hate those Trump supporters or
you really hate this then you have to
own how much you hate what's good like
you have to go I'm so angry that I'm
creating it coming at me from that
direction all the time because I'm not
dealing with my anger so I have so much
anger that everybody's pissing me off
every day that's like it that's only
coming up because you're so hey if I
release that anger I won't find
realities if I say nah man we're not
trying to cast anger it's more that we
like it's like when you go behind the
vehicle it has to respond but you don't
want to eat food buying the florists and
responding responsibly responsibly and
what's happening is the beauty of this
whole thing is you get really intimate
and personal with yourself because in
that scenario where I was angry it was
my adolescent not dealing with authority
issues and it was my child dealing with
the Thor
shoes and they were both pissed the [ __ ]
off and instead of me feeling shitty
about myself or guilty oh I shouldn't be
feeling these feelings because that's
the most of us her top anger is not okay
it's not okay to get mad at someone else
it's like I've told my adolescent my
child that their whole lives growing up
that's not okay and now I'm saying it's
okay to be angry what's wrong with being
[ __ ] angry it's just anger it's an
emotion so it's like when I went and
responded and I heard them and I knew
that they were having a tantrum was like
I'm nothing
okay good about my day because now my
dress my day will manifest in a terrible
way right so it was like I have to
respond to them right now I have to let
them come out and say what they want to
say and not do it in a way that's like
trying to guide them in and reframe and
say oh you know teach them it's like no
come out and [ __ ] say what you want
to say however you want to say that
however gnarly it is just because you're
angry doesn't mean they did it you're
the one angry you're not contextualizing
reality properly you're taking content
in you're agreeing with a set of past
and say yeah yeah instead of going No
I'm getting super mad I'm the one that's
not taking the context and creating it
right the problem with everybody's ego
is it's contextualizing experience for
you and you're not choosing the context
your your context is being driven by a
set of beliefs that are getting
triggered and because you're getting
triggered you say yeah I [ __ ]
here you're all wrapped up in your own
beliefs that you don't recognize you're
not contextualizing experience I'm not
in charge right now if I'm not
contextual my adolescent is or my child
is mine
yeah it's like you look at you know we
look at the universal examples Trump so
many people are triggered now all kinds
of stuff coming from Trump but you have
to ask yourself who does Trump symbolize
for me right what does he symbolize in
my life is the authority is a racist as
you what is it so as soon as you take
the symbol you're not not personal with
Trump it's a it's not Trump it's the
symbol for my in my psyche so then I can
now go okay where did that symbol show
up throughout my past if I want to heal
this so I can look at all the symbols of
authority or whatever Trump means for me
from my past and by all and then I find
one that's juicy and then at that point
that's where you go connect to that
memory with your childhood this is where
it gets really intimate and important
because you're coming in now with just
love you're setting your space today I'm
gonna come love this I'm not gonna
separate from this was a painful
experience maybe it was a father who
abused me whatever it might be
I will not separate I can't get rid of
you separated from it originally to
survive that's why it's still with you
and so you're going back to actually put
the pieces together and that's the
beautiful part that's where this art
form because it is an art form becomes
absolutely beautiful because when you go
back and you bring these pieces together
and you feel it authentically and you
healed and forgave and now it's clear
you feel unbelievable you just now step
into a whole new reality and literally
what happens is you start seeing
miracles from this reality once you once
you've cleared that all of a sudden
something's gonna come back to you
that's like holy [ __ ] I didn't even
expect that Lizabeth forgave her dad's
and her dad came and asked her for
forgiveness yeah I forgave my mom the
very next day she came and spoke to me
about the very thing that I went back
and went and cleared and clean and she
came just came to me with it and that's
why it's an art form because once you
understand that reality is an expression
of my beliefs nothing more
the minute the universe is just
mirroring Who I am because
universe is the realm of possibility
your spark and conscious that came in
and the whole thing morphed around your
set and as soon as I change my set it
just changes you don't have to control
you don't have to dominate anybody
anymore you just have to have a dominion
of yourself and then once you actually
realize that and you go through a shift
and your mom comes tomorrow and says
something you know that you that came
out of the work I did and it becomes
like wow oh wow it just trips you the
[ __ ] out because you start recognizing
the reality God being that you really
are so the belief creates the reality
the belief creates the experience yes
belief is points with the old paradigm
is about control and so that's what
their discrimination when does control
look like it's like I hate Trump I hate
what he's doing cuz it's wrong on on
community are you dad and so I'm right
you're wrong and I'm gonna fix your
thinking and you want me to leave this
country that's control when you're not
realizing how you control is by creating
so forget control like you will change
the president when you fix why you're in
the first place so you do not control
the form you've got to go in and like
correct yours you have to unplug
yourself from that because that is a
reflection of me I have to unplug myself
I have to move past my anger my rage my
disempowerment all whatever he labeled
whatever you can say is what it is is
what I have to change and then he would
change see would and I will describe I
like this I use this example it's so if
you were to stand in front of a mirror
put a mirror
I do you see that infinity illusion
right where you see yourself go for
infinity so the person that you are at
right now has a certain set of beliefs
now imagine you can move down the line
to a person who has let's say it's a
belief that you're struggling with right
now is the limitation on money so it's
like money doesn't come to me easily or
I have to work really hard for money but
imagine you're able to shift down the
line of use of all these uses in the
mirror to a different version of
yourself that believes money comes to me
easily what would his life look like you
get what I'm saying it'd be completely
different universe so as soon as you
shift your belief that's what happens
you shift down the ladder point on your
own and it's a whole new universe it's
not the same universe that you were just
in and it happens instantly so he is to
shift our beliefs towards the form to
function towards the work you wanted me
to contextualize and not worry about the
content the collective is just the way
my filtering system is going but the way
I feel inside has nothing to do with
this I can't let reality invalidate me
or validate me really it's an illusion
it's a mirror of me why how's the mirror
gonna validate a sovereign in your
beliefs yes alternate those are the
notes cause and effect versus resonance
foundation positive echo people are
living in it I'm mad because you pissed
me off
I'm mad because your should be present
I'm not gonna write this [ __ ] we weren't
doing that I would be mad so we're not
in our own authority we're not
responsible for self we're not creating
like from a beautiful place and so if
you can shift to the new paradigm it's
and not being positive in fact well if
you stop doing that than I stopped
feeling this way if you would just leave
that might be better no it's like I
created that with other great that let
me figure out how I created that and
unemployment now I should say so that's
the difference between cause and effect
versus residence causation and it's
crazy because as we've all done this
we've all shifted people in our lives
because that's the crazy part is once
you've shifted down the line to this new
person to this new
set the people in your lives aren't the
same either it's a whole new universe so
you're in a relationship that's a
struggle and you get down to the bottom
of why you have created a belief that
this is a struggle right whatever it is
you believe about this person and then
you shift that belief the person will
either leave your reality or they'll
change they'll be a different person and
you'll be blown out on you can't think
that human homeopathic to make the world
a better place when you're judging
everybody who you think is not doing it
the way you think it should be you're
separating from the experience that I
have to own the parts of myself that
have taken this long to understand what
I've been doing like it's got to be a
moment of forgiveness that alters this
it's got to be a release of a way that
I'm being the adolescent inside loves to
argue and fight that's why it is just
dog line no dialogue mm yeah it's
adolescent behavior interesting so we
have rampant Dogma and not so much
dialogue because it's like catalyst one
opinion again nobody's got the
experience it's an opinion against an
opinion against opinion it Sosa versus
the eight billion people having their
own beliefs that we haven't even
sovereignly decided that we're all in
complete conscious creation with our
beliefs creating our experiences so
because that isn't there
that's part of maybe what you could call
like maybe like a like a spiritual
fragmentation of sources they identify
with their past that isn't that's the
way you were programmed that's not who
you are most of the time that program
has nothing to do with you are and
that's why you're so unhappy ah I have
to write my own program somewhere I have
to get out of that set and redesign a
set for myself
works right and so that's a process
everything in physical reality is
ultimately a process don't bring me fun
so lucky don't back but more elevated
place you see we are analyzing
everything rather than understanding we
have to synthesize everything if I have
in a moment we're arguing we share a
resonance if one of us unplug that the
argument will fall apart immediately
that's how you know what you view it
like inside while you're into it you go
what do I need to forget what do I need
right it's an art form I have to get
better and I'd understand now it happens
in real time fast your Creator you're
like oh wow I'm pissed because
somebody's pissed in front of me and I'm
getting triggered so there's some anger
to deal let me be open and listen to
what are the hints and clues of what's
pissing the off inside what can i align
with it in fact is like yeah they're
judging me or they're they're looking at
me as a lesser person and you see you've
got to take that apart and I plug that
and if you unplug if you're good at it
which you can get good at it you'll see
the argument fall apart you don't have
to tell them anything you just unplug
yourself and you say in resonance
causation you are operating by the law
of resonance and the law of resonance
states when you get to vibrations
there's only three things that happen to
those they either one will come down one
will go up or the Harmonized somewhere
in the middle those are unconscious
vibrations now if I'm conscious and I
know mine is coming from love and I know
what I'm doing these will come up to you
for sure they cannot not like if you get
an argument you start saying she do
these two images escalates via
homeopathic you have to be the healer
you
different thing and it can't be out of
the judgment okay so so we so we we
anchor love and then that's the
resonance that we hold and then we know
to make picture sense yes and then we
don't cast judgment on to eight billion
other people why they're just is because
of just Miami less in the time it all
aspects of you I mean eight billion
versions of something inside of them
because they don't exist when you leave
it I mean would you say that this is a
was this forgiving yeah well when you
going back and you're forgiving your
adolescent your child and all you were
past all of that sort unbind emotionally
so now that it's not as arable who are
limiting you you're the one that agreed
with those limitations placed on you you
have to disagree with them in a positive
way now you were programmed and you
might hate it and you might not like it
you feel limited and you feel crappy but
if you don't understand how to reprogram
them to take that out and up create
myself in a sense and do it honestly you
can't reframe and separate oh I'm just
gonna move on just we're gonna let that
go
no you won't you just you're just hiding
from it now when you let it go you know
you let it go you know what you do it
and reality has communicated to me that
I let it go if reality doesn't
communicate that back you've got more to
do because it's an illusion it's a
reflection of you you need to use the
reality appropriately as a god being
it's an illusion I'm here to create I'm
here to create the more real and bring
it into this experience not try to get
the experience to change for me okay
rather than trying to get the experience
to change for you it's about you
consciously creating and let it be the
mirror let me know when I've changed is
when it falls apart and the proof is in
the pudding if you're doing it it
happens and you know you're doing it
when you're doing it see most people are
in the sense they don't understand what
I'm talking about everybody sitting
around here knows what
talking about they've done it I can talk
about it all day but until you meet a
person who's done it and can talk that
language you can understand there's a
there's a there's a synergy that also
happens right there's this is a greater
than me being alone on camera with you
this is a greater my breakup it's more
deep it's wider it's more profound in a
sense because now there's four people
sitting here that understand how to
create reality and consciousness
yeah we have amazing light all of us I
mean it's it's super fun for me to watch
it's that's the cool part like I'm
saying it's art it's cool I've always
wanted to go for art my whole life this
is like the purest form of art because
you touch into so much love I gotta say
when you're talking about judgement when
you see the rest of all the world doing
crazy [ __ ] you've gone back and you've
connected to the child and the
adolescent inside of you and you love
them and you've gained greater
unconditional love for yourself so how
is someone even going to come into my
rowdy and really actually piss me off
you get what I'm saying like piss me off
to the point where I'm like but you you
know you like it it doesn't happen the
same because now I have so much more
love for myself that's really what it's
like you've gotten in touch with
yourself pieces of you that you left a
long time ago and so now that you've
connected in that way your whole world
becomes more intimate so now you see
just adolescents and children around in
the world and you're just like fine I
feel for you I have in if you have so
much more empathy now because I know you
I know myself and I what you want to
open to that when you realize I see what
a resume and a lot of times right then
the other person I'll just relax
I'm right on right on point right now
inside because I saw in real-time then
go down when I opened it's like you need
to use physical reality as a mirror
that's what it was designed for it
that's what it is again people don't
know that because they weren't taught
you specifically now therefore I am here
to consciously create yes to have
sovereign beliefs to create your
experiences in your reality so your
imagination is the most point tool you
have and right now I think therefore
have all the emphasis has been on the
mind thinking and hasn't been on the
sense of being an emotional being you
see like I said that's why I say your
mind is the brushes that I feel
therefore I create I feel therefore I am
therefore I am he didn't come in
thinking he came in feeling and
everything was taken care of for him
until they say no terrible twos they're
not conscious of himself yet that's
their first I have a preference no I
know that's why I know is so profound to
them because all of a sudden I'm not you
I have my own I'm not my mother I'm not
aligned with her psychologically anymore
it's a separation you first said
physically then you have to step you
separate emotionally that's the next
separation terrible twos are an
emotional separation from source then
now my mind is started again and I
I'm learning language and I'm
understanding how thing can be before
that this is an experience of receiving
so that should be a celebration then
when they first say no ya know what I
mean I said oh my god oh my god I can't
control video oh god he's overrated it's
either adolescent is raising a child as
what's happening right there you're not
an empowered adult or you know I've
never gotten upset I've never picked him
up upset either as she week he's been
unconditionally loved very consciously
because I want his his experience of
reality the unconscious person him to
know he's good enough nobody has enough
he's an egomaniac
no matter how much he gets it's not
enough and you have boundaries you can
only give so much but when I haven't
when I stop I can't give you anymore I
don't do it like that's it I've done
crap no I'm like ahold of it I'm sorry I
can't help you right now I love you and
I just hold him look bright but he's not
crying because I'm like it's just gonna
have to cry it out you know gotta be
tough on kids need to be tough if you
don't toughen him up they don't learn
now earlier the better
yeah program early and they come out
more even more difficult more hard for
them to find themselves more control
because all they're picking up is not to
control myself they're not they can't
think it through all they know about to
control myself I must concur control
myself and then they're mad you have a
kid that's blowing up all the time he
blows up everybody does because they're
egomaniacs the child ego isn't am i
getting enough no I just had everything
fulfilled for me without question
without thought without anything now I
come in in a new space and it's not
working on it's a paradigm shift to come
out of your mother no I'm trying to
figure out what's going on but I'm still
in a hundred percent state of receiving
when I entered this I I have to lose
that state of receiving in order to
consciously re instill that in myself
later in life when I no choice and I
know what I want
able to receive it specifically now so
you must cut your adolescent you cut
yourself and adolescent purpose you cut
yourself on a soul level because I get
the taste of being as powerful amazing
human being who I just won't have sex
I'm gonna do what I want I don't want
your ideas anymore and then you cut
yourself and you lose it you just get a
taste of what it's like to be be adult
but you can't be ended up coming from
there it has to be self authored so in
the healing process I do as an adult I
incorporate all the positive stuff for
the child and I incorporated positive
stuff in the adolescent and I leave the
negative stuff healed behind now you're
functioning as a multi-dimensional being
without limitation because you know if I
get if I hit a wall tomorrow I know how
to take that out oh it's just the steps
to get into where you want are the
qualities of being there and the
qualities of being there tell me the
steps I need to get but it's like you
have to understand it you're not perfect
you're not gonna do anything perfectly
and enlightenment isn't being perfectly
met oh I'm not getting mad yeah that's
that's the adolescent version of what
like that would if I was really happy
I'd be like stress-free and not mad and
not all these things so the adolescent
sees enlightenment as this is enabling
me to create so powerfully I need all
crammed 56 trans not
through him and just take the ones out
you don't like it throw away I don't
have resource that way anymore
your emotions are reason to be angry
honestly openly in the moment it puts
the brakes
that's the brakes of physical reality if
I lose my [ __ ] right here everybody's
gonna [ __ ] the whole reality stops cold
that's what anger is for and now if you
disempowered say it's not good you have
no brakes on the car anymore
you have no capacity to stop what's
going on I see something going on I
don't have to go you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] I have to say god yeah what are
you doing what are you doing right now I
need to know that so I can find what's
inside it unplug this experience that
I'm sharing you can't resonate if you
don't you can't resonate with an idea if
you can't watch a person totally angry
and not knowing that I'm totally angry I
would not be seeing this not like now
you're just pissing them off I'm so cool
you're so much really I'm angry is [ __ ]
and I'm just trying to act like because
I can't share that experience I have to
be like I'm in freakin denial if I say
I'm not angry I'm trying to be that like
it doesn't work it's not working cuz
it's not working now it hasn't worked so
far and it won't if you're seeing a
split and a paradigm people that are
having dreams it's just that the unless
it's think there's only one percent of
the people can't change now you're
diverse another people get [ __ ] by
some other Authority out because you
haven't really resolved being an
authority yet you're still seeing I'm
being limited by the outside because the
child or the adolescent words they don't
have the capacity self offer they have
no experience all I have is put my bear
program me pre verbally most of it you
see so I'm living in an experience that
I don't know how to author I don't know
how to take responsibility because the
adolescent actually believes
responsibilities and duty and obligation
not power the light versus like I'll
take that I'll take that let me take
that let me let me fix this I your I see
you Liang and I want to know I want to
understand more about my own anger
because I'm not saying like the dialogue
that's where the dialogue comes from is
understanding it's not you're not alone
right now I wouldn't be seeing this if I
didn't have it in me I'd be seeing
somebody else without it take
responsibility because it gives us power
yeah yeah power and responsibility
directly 100% equally correlate I don't
have the ability to respond I have no
power
right America the reason America is so
powerful because we're in a paradox
powerful to do what the [ __ ] I want in
the world but I also have to create
security safety security for myself and
others how do i navigate that that's
where your vibration lands in between
the paradigms of creating sake because I
also have to do a free I can't control
you and tell you can't do that anymore
because you're taking advantage of the
planet and everything around it's like
that's just a way old way of being of
dominating you the university said of
like having that I'd like to call we win
wins I have a wind you have a winning
everything in this environment must have
a win to be a right complex decision and
it takes patient and dialogue to come up
with a win win win most people have one
wins good enough it's me there's got to
be a loser that's the way it goes you
don't know you we both need to win and
that that's why relationships it's not
5050 it's 100 100 it's not like oh I'm
trying to do
they're not really growing I'm not
growing my partner because they want no
no that's not what it is it's like you
need to respond 200% to them
you are not here to be loved or
understood you're here that opportunity
to love and understand someone that they
become their best self right in front of
me because of the love I have and when
you do that you were gonna want to deal
with another person and another person
in another person it's not not even just
people because the way it is is you have
two positions right so it could be you
and money but what's the other edge
between you and money is the
relationship that's third position right
and that's a bridge and you decide what
do I bring if you're only coming 50
because you're waiting for the other
person to come other way 50 right what
are you gonna get you're not going to
get the results you want
you have to be the one willing to go on
hunger and you stop the creators of it
you see control well people don't
understand the minute I have four
control like I put in 50% where's your
50% I'm not loving I'm not coming up
with a creative solution to move past
this and I'm not free now I'm totally
your concern trump is controlling all
these people who are mad at no matter
how mad you are he's controlling the
[ __ ] out of you because everything he
does is pissing you off and making you
scream and freak out and go pick it and
go tell on your friends like let's get a
repeat you're so caught up and that you
don't even see the forest through the
trees you just don't recognize I have a
very poor relationship of the sort trem
doesn't bother me in the least I didn't
vote for him either but I know he's the
icon for how we're doing as a whole he
represents the icon on his computer
screen here's what it looks like when we
punch authority figure right now we're
railing against say baby boomers in
their attitude because people aren't
recognizing the power of the baby boomer
and they just don't like any of it
because the Millennials were a
generation that could not supersede
those guys they were so hardcore they
went the other way so that's why the
Millennials were so on board with Bernie
Yeah right there man is with the office
they're mad man they want the power like
let's just take it away from her let's
just force them to we'll work you know
that won't work because that's not you
do it you need to let go of a
generations negative stuff and take what
was awesome about them and implement in
to be more complex with the Nugent not a
separation from but an understanding I
we're at a higher level do already
facility don't we're another level you
must synthesize what was release what
wasn't the baby-boomers has amazing
qualities that she's one half but it
needs to be uplifted not just a win
anymore it doesn't be a win-win-win you
just take that will that they had take
that full on balls to the walls just go
after what you want but be coming from
the right place now and so if you
separate from all that and judge all
that and try to make it even we're going
to make it even it's not going to work
the relationship the universe is not it
it's not really in a 50/50 black and
white harmony in order for it to create
more for itself it has to be out of
balance it has to be out of balance to
keep continuously creating human beings
the only thing out of harmony because
you have the back the capacity to direct
the harmony to direct where it goes and
that's the power of being a God being we
need to nurture nature you don't have to
think you just fill in the blanks nature
will help you many of the ancient great
minds are just copy nature and find out
what nature's doing understand and then
follow that road because it's the most
elegant way to do it if we were really
like trying to elevate the planet we
would take care of your [ __ ] backyard
if you don't have a you have a balcony
make that balcony beautiful show your
love for the environment put something
even if I'm only putting this much
oxygen in this much beauty do it quit
telling everybody else they need to wake
up and do it just do it feel good with
your relationship with nature feel good
with the really
ships that I'm developing around me feel
good that my yard is the best-looking
one on the block because I love my
neighborhood and somebody else will get
inspired and probably accept their yard
I'd give you a let me and I see you're
trying to help you yeah let me help you
dude I'm really good at this like that's
all it takes
to be empowered in my own set of values
if I value that then I must go after my
that I will feel wonderful on my way to
change it's a different paradigm
operating yeah how do we create win-win
wins you have to sit there dialogue you
can't be a dog you've got to say like
why do you want Trump out because but
right now I have to understand because I
don't like he's crass well I see plenty
people fighting and arguing under plenty
crafts in their pursuit of arguing the
pros and cons of the government right
there being arrogant they're not
listening they're not I mean I have
people all the time you know I don't get
on Facebook very much anymore but a lot
of time I do just because they want to
get into it a little bit and see I want
to push on the reality you know like I
plus another bonus thing purposely the
other day and I knew the whole trend was
gonna blow up and it was like she did
this long thing shame dumping on a gun
and give her a massage and he had that
having sex with her and she felt like oh
I can't believe he would do that and I'm
like all I said was like didn't you
allow it
why are you posting and trying to shame
him and posting your dialogue and saying
he cut you off this is your problem he
doesn't want to talk to you so what what
you can't peel that because in case I
have to be he's gonna release me it's
that you're not understanding that
everybody was just firing on big Bam Bam
and then here so instead yeah that's a
baby boomer that you're the typical man
we're trying to change as a good luck
with that I was born in nineteen
three I have a baby boomer but I'm right
on the cusp I understand what's
happening and I also understand what I'm
not letting go of the willfulness though
I want to be a man in a man's world and
that doesn't mean that women aren't
included you understand you say that and
everybody gets triggered in a man's
world I know what that means no you
don't you know what your beliefs are
around what that means and you're
experiencing them but you don't know
what I mean by it
you don't even you're not even taking
the time to find out like my search shop
and I open it was surf like a girl the
first time I got a radio in a big letter
like oh so you're basically demeaning
women you're saying surf like a girl
right I think no you're misunderstanding
because I'm saying surf like you go out
there and receive the water be that
mermaid out there enjoying your zombie
fun while the guys are packing on the
waves like they're go out there and just
surf like a woman you will change the
whole industry just surfing like from
your soul from from your heart from go
you go on the way guys are going the
girls like go you go their whole vibe is
different that's why I wanted to promote
that I wanted women to be the one there
weren't even women wetsuits in 1999 I
knew I was part of that and I did it on
purpose to be part of that I wanted to
create an image so anyway it's like
acting up of preferences supercharges
what you're going after and it's
supercharges your limitations because
the minute you stretch yourself BAM
you're gonna get hit by the limitation
that you were programmed well you're
talking about was how to create a
win-win Oh
and when win is function there's so much
good yes so I'll give you an example so
couples trying to decide what
what movie to watch on a Friday night
and both of them pick a movie that they
think this is the movie that I want and
then they get in an argument it's got to
be this or it's got to be that yeah yeah
as long as like okay good I want to get
laid later I'll get away you was right
exactly so minions of the whole
manipulation game whereas if you were
going on function it's not the movie
that's gonna give you the feeling you're
saying well what's the feeling that I
want tonight you're not going for the
movie using what's the feeling
so then both people can sit there and
talk about the film I want to feel cozy
I want maybe a romantic you know I mean
what if the romance I want to feel at
home want to feel warm and then they
that's where they merge like oh that and
then all of a sudden you'll connect with
the movie that is a win-win for both you
don't compromise that's the thing but
the adolescent says we'll then that to
be being stubborn and no no no you don't
compromise the function you compromise
the form so you have dialogue to figure
out that's optimal sociable share our
functions it might be a third movie yeah
or maybe not or mine even in the movie
yeah yeah and if we're gonna connect the
movies not really the best idea cuz
we're gonna sit there watch the movie
disconnected we're doing you understand
once you get to the forum I mean the
function you will find the form that
resonates for you both and now you're
both making an empowered choice that's a
win-win
okay so creating win wins is dialogue
about the function so it's so in a
sensitive be like can we know what would
you guys say about this having a more a
more love based dialogue around the
trajectory of our world yeah yeah
everybody know what FERC - what
everything is a reflection of your
beliefs every single thing
reality I'm talking all that like people
could say well I understand my own world
but you know how am I responsible for
your feelings because I'm sharing the
feelings or we wouldn't be sharing the
moment so I'm going to respond to you
appropriately I'm gonna be like wow I
really feel your pain like maybe not say
it out loud but internally like like to
try to heal them to try to get in
alignment and get sympathy sympathetic
is to be in simpatico it as soon as
we're connected I can release that and
you'll start releasing and you'll find
your way just for me you're sitting here
listening it's like to have a win-win it
requires to come from love and
understand I can only change this
reality but once I get good at this I
can change the reality the whole room
full of people I could change around in
a host stadium I could change the whole
paradigm it only takes one person to
change the world it's not like we got
eight billion people all doing the wrong
thing this is awful
one percent point zero zero one percent
as awake right now it's never gonna one
person can do it all
I'm not worried I know that I'm gonna
create this beautifully yeah I'm not
worried about Trump I'm not worried
about where the world I don't look I'm
sad about the fight deeply bums me to
watch those fires but I know that's the
adolescent and so I just burned the
[ __ ] place down unconsciously because
I'm sick of this I hate it I want it
different there comes reality boom just
burning down the thing that you're so
afraid to lose more for us we're gonna
die because the logic and reason is
saying not seeing how oxygen is and all
the logical linear thought which is not
even true it's an illusion science does
not even know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about for the most part right
now they're trying to come up with a way
to to create it in a paradigm that we
could follow into the future that's
paradigm is too slow I can get real-time
results in reality why am I going to
need to
myself that it works Wow I stopped the
fires by meditation because I'll tell
you I did a lot of work this weekend and
as soon as it would rain came and 40% of
the fire was out by the time I came out
of meditation and I oh that I did that
because I'm already trying to work on
that level I know I can change
individuals in front of me I know I can
change a room full of people I'm already
working can I change the whole thing now
I'm more into that position because I've
got the confidence I've got the
self-esteem I've been doing this for 30
years I cute I died and put myself back
in with this thinking that took the
opinion that I had and made it an
experience now there's nobody gonna
shake me off of this base and so I'm not
stubborn
on finding an answer for a win-win with
everyone I'm into it I'm going for the
functions and people get mad because
they want the forum I want that guy to
be I want all guys to recognize what
it's like to be a woman that when I say
no you don't listen and most of the time
if you're a woman blending sex and you
say no and you have sex anyways you
wanted sex so you never would have had
it you have to say wow I have a whole
blockage trying to say no and try to be
in my power and really I just really
want more sex but I want to say no it's
like they're not getting that because
they're creating that I say no all the
time and they never listen at a
different belief coming out that's not a
problem with men it's a problem with my
belief about men that are being shown to
me and all the men I keep picking then
people say that that kind of way of
speaking is insensitive like the other
thing I would say is that it's so much
more loving though because when it's in
real talking like this what he's saying
is nobody is a victim like there's
nothing about what's being taught here
that you're a victim so even with the
most hardcore tragedies it's actually an
act of love to say these insensitive
things because whether it's really
saying is you are so powerful and you
create every moment of your life maybe
you didn't know what your
but now you can now have an opportunity
I know that I'm not gonna let anybody
get away when I've got a choke hold on
that innocence I'm hardcore like I think
when I have to do that with the people
that trust me because there's times
they're not they're gonna be so scared
they want to go back to the pattern it's
like no no no we just ran into some of
that too
you know and they'll realize they need
an anchor you need another human being
to help sometimes to be that resource
that's Lauren see mine is not coming for
opinion I'm like who should I push right
now maybe I should this is getting
really scary there really like something
no I know what I'm doing I'm creating
reality and I'm gonna create the realize
that you're healed what would we say
that this is a adventure of the hero or
the heroine into chaos in order for them
to bring their gift more forth into the
world and as they go on to that process
there aren't those moments of just
absolute uncertainty fear you need that
critical anchor in the relationship
either intimate with my business
intimate with money it doesn't matter I
just have to have an intimate connection
with something and right now everybody's
avoiding that because they're afraid I
was gonna when we were working I was
gonna drop off I was like in the midst
and this side but I had this person that
I love and trust I'm intimate with able
to anchor me when I was like in the
midst of my adolescent and child just
running wild and I didn't know what I
was gonna do I've had it with Rick where
there's been times I'm just kind of like
skipping back and he's held the line for
me and says no they can't even in
forceful way where Ivan felt like even
angry and wanting to go to battle with a
knife
when they're there I know this is their
breakthrough I'm gonna go and I'm gonna
go that's me that's my energy that's you
know it's not finished from your spirit
right it's coming through an experience
that I know they have to get through
this and so I'm loving them and come on
where'd you go just now where did you
just go you're worried right and then
you ask them questions this is a part of
the process I lead them with questions
because once you intimate with the
Petersons you know where their
limitations are you know how they're
going to view something they don't have
it they're stuck in the set you're
outside of their set you have every
potential to help them see what they're
not seeing if you're close and not just
coming from an opinion I read the book
well this is what I read this book and I
think you should do it no it's coming
out of my relationship and my love for
you and the trust that you have for me
and you see that whole machine creates
an exponentially different result like
something you didn't even imagine you'd
get out of it because of the resonance
that's being okay so what so when there
are moments of difficulty we have better
dialogue more conscious dialogue and ask
questions to catalyze growth the
questions you're asking should be to ask
the reflection about yourself tell you
more about how mad you are because
you're like I don't even see the anger
this person so mad I need to ask them to
trigger myself so I can find my own rage
like what's bothering you so much right
now
please tell me well I don't
oh that tells me something I can feel
that so you changed your questions are
really chasing yourself and what I want
to just add to this though because when
we were talking earlier about how you
shift a belief and now the you know the
person in the relationship through with
ships as well your souls are connected
your souls are playing the form is
what's shifting right it's a form so
easy to shift so if I shift my belief
might heal something it's not like I'm
changing that person right though I
don't I didn't like that let's flip
through there cuz I get I found
something that I connected to that I was
able to heal and align with and now I'm
feeling good in my whole reality is
different but our souls are what's still
connecting so it's intimate it's through
love so what he's saying I'm asking
someone a question you're not trying to
just get from them right it's not that
kind of asking asking to find out about
money you're asking because you know our
souls are playing a game yeah it's
coming with your job to find the
resonant connection inside yourself like
okay I'm not conscious of my anger right
now but this person is so let me ask the
questions to be like why are you so mad
that's a negative judgment basically
saying you're so immature right now no
like tell me more why you so mad yeah
yeah you see that's a same question not
the same yeah because you're looking
inside honestly like I need to find my
anger so we could get on the same page
right now what are you angry about tell
me more and as soon as you fight you're
like oh I see that I have to forgive
that in myself and then the person
starts changing so this has been a lot
about also interpersonal
annex and end about just that conscious
reality creation I want us to talk on I
want us to talk about source
specifically about what is this
manifestation of source this you only
get manifestation you're calibrated
experience of source because source is
unlimited and you are so you grow up
with an idea of what sources that's been
given you adopt that situation right so
now God is either an angry [ __ ] bad
dad or I pushed that away and say there
is no God or right go with paganism say
it's really a goddess it's like you
don't really recognize that it is in
depth is very clear to me that God is
primarily feminine there's a more
significant part of what it is the
synergy between God that is feminine and
there's not diminishing it air and fire
represents spirit soul is represented by
earth and why it's more dense and it's a
different thing but together they create
all that is and so the masculine is the
dynamism like when the God like the way
I like this guy's was just kicking it
and self-realized in the moment that she
recognized she was gone I mean that's
what I'm just giving you some example
the moment that she she was blown out
and that minute of being blown out the
masculine was created in that moment and
from that moment on everything was done
together it's it's a complex sources at
complex vibration sources so light so
much if they were to enter right now you
would just [ __ ] blow up immediately
because the vibration is so high you
would have to go meet them and you would
your entire thing so you created a
rendition that you can relate to but
that's not God that is only the way that
you're relating to it because it's off
creating other [ __ ] already it gave you
the spark of what it is it's out so we
have our own unique communions with the
higher of the divine with the divine
yeah okay it's another set of beliefs so
out of the eight billion of us maybe so
some people are just not connecting with
a higher power with the divine most all
a billion aren't it would be experience
what the issues is this way yes so it's
almost as though the the challenge level
is set up cranked up to 11 right now and
it's like how is there a consciousness
right thank you 11 is the fact that
you're trying to expand in a new place
and you have a baggage and this cannot
go in that new space so you're
stretching yourself so hard it's
creating pain pain is a function of a
synergy between two aspects separation
from and longing for that creates pain
if you unplug one of those you won't be
in pain anymore it's that easy I mean
theoretically but what's happening you
know they get your limitation ascend
into the night you're on your limited
belief constructs cannot enter a new
paradigm it's so what's happening is
since it's you still technically enter
the new paradigm reality's creating more
intensely and faster than ever before
because you really are the God being
it's all the past is already released
itself and you are actually in the mode
of creating so now it feels like you're
the only way you have to frame that is
the challenges are getting more hardcore
than ever know your negative beliefs are
being more realized more than ever in
order for me to change them more
really see the pain I'm in in order for
me to really understand how limited I
feel and you have to come to that
realization in order for that paradigm
to let go
and nobody's taught us that nobody
taught us what it was to be an adult
that's why the adult is a self authored
self determined position if you cannot
move into adulthood you cannot move into
the new paradigm so this one is going to
[ __ ] real fast but everybody knows
there's some people out there living a
dream some of my friends are crushing in
there that's because you still have to
create that you still know the truth is
I get out whatever I want so no matter
how bad it gets there's always somebody
in reality that's crushing it easily see
cuz you can't really create all of an
untruth so how more of us see so more of
us connect so as we connect to the
divine higher power more of us will
connect to the divine and a higher power
your reflection with it you really do it
inside you just start me Joe to start on
a connect whoa you know you're doing
yeah if I keep doing it and nobody's
connected and I'm an island of a man
alone you're not doing it yeah Oh which
is crazy I forgot to tell you guys about
this we were having sushi with my
parents on their anniversary I was
telling them all about conscious reality
creation all this stuff and then some
dude sitting next to us was overhearing
it he was like man who's like that's
some crazy stuff and he started going
off and started sharing you know he's
like where do you learn sometimes like
Rick Paris is like oh I know Rick Paris
he was like local guy right subconscious
on something I was like yeah I was like
nobody videos right you're not creating
the outcome the outcome oh boy well it's
like here I had this amazing thing
happening to me and I didn't keep
creating the outcomes I said oh that's
enough I had this amazing connecting
yeah tell me more what's your name right
you you just didn't keep creating see
most people who create an outcome and go
wow the fire stop that's so awesome but
now and I want I want the government to
change I want to take this win and keep
pushing the reality to stay intimate
with the experience and keep pushing it
through because it could go anywhere I'm
riding a wave right now and so that's
what I mean to be an artist that
conscious reality Chris is to realize
everything I've always traded in the
outcome it's not enough just to get what
I want when we're done you know now what
do I want Marcus now this or better this
or more you see most people will be like
wow I just had a winner I should just
chill out because I could lose it I mean
I mean so now that was probably the
place I hit to in the conversation
somewhere this is my people yeah just
enough right yeah just enjoy life
there's always this belief around like
and if I don't give it away everyone's
gonna think I'm a dick yeah cuz I'm
killing it I'm not sharing your other
share [ __ ] what you have to do and I
move you're right really if you're
making 10 billion dollars a year do
something awesome spend that [ __ ] just
the way you want to make the room don't
give it to somebody else to make
world a better place you're the one
generating that why give it because we
think that I'm a good person when I
enable somebody else no that's probably
some system that 3% of that money will
get somewhere and a bunch of other
people are just taking that money put in
their pocket cuz that's the old paradigm
I'm gonna set up a non-profit thing that
other people know people are making
money I've seen plenty of nonprofits
where they're getting a lot of money and
they're utilizing that money in a way
that legally makes it look like they're
not but it's a game it's a play right
so it's like you don't have to give
anything but like if I'm gonna make ten
million dollars in my life I only need 1
million dollars a year I still gotta
take responsibility for that night Billy
and I generated and keep what am I gonna
do with this like what am I gonna do
with this money
I love that about if you get a big win
desire another big yes because y'all
wait yeah you're already in the zone to
be creating that it's the best time to
ask for more mmm not go back to the
other Billy I should be happy with what
I got
because you see I should be happy with
what I got no you should want more mmm
because it's an illusion you can have as
much illusion as you want right you
should this is again this is though I
will and I want this because I want to
bring myself fully to the world unleash
mine exactly this is a vehicle for me to
be more to be more to be mindful because
if I make that much I don't wanna do it
so I might give it away everybody gets
off my back and everyone thinks I'm a
good person cuz I did all that and since
I have so much money it doesn't really
matter anyway they're not really being
empowered individuals you know like
that's why I blow your money I'm doing
this because these are stupid people I'm
gonna buy before stuff because
everybody's so stupid I mean nobody
force up because I'm gonna get a care
take care I'm gonna make this place
beautiful it's going to be a [ __ ]
park it's going to have boundaries
around it because this is what I love in
the world that this is what I'm putting
my money like no no powers just no no
it's gotta be a framework everything in
physical reality has a set and it has to
be recreated in a new set and a new set
so basically the first thing you ain't
learning conscious reality is I got a
destroy a lot of [ __ ] and recreate after
you realized I can destroy it with grace
and elegance and love not because I
don't like it and I want it out of here
but because it doesn't serve me anymore
and it did serve me for a long time
religions were designed by people trying
to [ __ ] with human beings it only looks
like it from here because it's so
limiting now you stayed in the same pot
to love your rootbound is all that
happened and now you're looking on it's
the stupid pot it doesn't have big
enough for us no that's it did at the
beginning it was a beautiful idea human
beings don't operate that way but if the
adolescent didn't he says yeah those
guys have been controlling us for years
and you didn't that's the adolescent
getting near you're going down the wrong
Avenue for saying so it's time for a
larger pot for the roots
yeah grow further a set a new set and so
then our set is constantly also
iterating and becoming bigger and bigger
doc if you're doing it consciously it
will if it's not you know keep narrowing
you down like my challengers are almost
unsurmountable now yeah yeah you're
doing the same thing that you're not in
charge on one end instead of going Wow
let me deal with this appropriately
people don't know what that means yet
they're all the world is in a state of
adolescence moving into adulthood as a
whole and the macrocosm
yes yes so if that's what needs to be
then that's what each person has to
become in order to change the paradigm
all you have to do right now
be an adult not the adolescents version
I gotta do everything right I should do
this when she'd pay my dad's
insemination yeah who wants to do all
that [ __ ] nobody so nobody's doing it
but they're mad that nobody's doing it's
like it's stuck in a set they don't know
how to get out so there's a lot static
and chaos you up tumble yourself because
when you ask questions about what the
step is the steps that usually been
talked about are all that like really
kind of positive looking ones I think in
general and let me know if I'm wrong the
first step for most everybody is
incredible no don't worry about for you
no I'm watching her reality she's
reframing a lot of things that I'm like
there's still a lot of anger in your
reality but remember this see this day
that that's a function of anger unplug
that it makes change you can see because
anger so intense it puts it cover in
front of you that you can't access the
compassion sweet and vulnerable parts of
yourself and so it's putting this shield
in front of you that you can feel it you
can't Wan without dealing with it either
because I can't move and like just I'm
fine it's gonna work I could stay over
the fence just because I got my hand all
over the fence doesn't mean that I'm
done
because reality still looks like there's
a lot of anger so let me just keep doing
that while I'm moving on not just well I
have to deal with my hand but I can't do
anything else with my anger no you deal
with your anger and you keep moving
toward your preference you know because
it what happened over releasing you'll
get a lot of you know wow I think I'm
done with anger you might be any might
not know but it doesn't mean you will be
done when you're done and you'll see it
and it doesn't have to be perfect like
if it used to be that 50 people a day
we're raging in front of me now there's
one or two that's good enough I don't
have to get every person not to rage it
just has to be good well enough I can
receive now I don't know what the deal
is you hit it that's the deal with your
anger you hit it because it was
inappropriate yeah most people so
because you hit it your reality hit it
from you too that's how this is gonna
make that happen so once you start
choosing to be conscious of your anger
it will start showing up right because
right now you may feel like you're not
angry and I don't know you know whatever
you may or may not be I'm not putting
that on you but you may feel that you're
not because your reality isn't actually
bringing too much because you told your
subconscious a certain point hide this
[ __ ] from me so once you start actually
diving into your anger it'll just start
oh no they see it no it's true it's true
because again it's out here not getting
your houses I mean it's not you so
they're seeing it it's yeah it's hard to
be true just because I don't care what's
going on up there in my house that's
still you what is the role of free will
your gut being that's all it is you God
took you and you at the same time when
God decided to split itself in a million
pieces he was releasing you from itself
that you can go be something unique
individual and so you leave now when you
leave just like you're in this beautiful
place everything is taking care of me
I'm part of God everything is awesome
now what I'm not God doesn't have to
come and teach you how to be God you
have to receive being God so you've
never been on your own before I've never
been a spark a conscious separated from
the whole before so what I do is when
all of a sudden I'm not being catered to
every desire I have I contextualise that
if something's wrong something's wrong
here I mean I'm not getting it writing
them so as a parent you go up and your
kids two years old you say they throw a
fit and the story if you look at us
right now dude and you just you slam
that kid inside right then because
you're God for all intents and purposes
so that kid goes I don't want to get mad
so right there's all this inappropriate
your stuffing anger for the rest of your
life because it's not appropriate to
express that [ __ ] because my parents
taught me not to so free will has now
been directed by God being my parents
because that's the game you're playing
or how to come out of them you're
mimicking what you did to be a free will
person so once you separate from God
goddess all it is now you're in chaos
and so I have to learn how to put myself
in harmony and learn that one I want
something new I have to put myself back
into chaos and that I have to go back
into harmony to put myself in again so
everyone's trying to avoid gas because
they don't like it because they don't
realize I'm a god creep being I have to
get very comfortable with chaos I have
to understand wow what a reality's
chaotic that means though the boundaries
are loose right now and they're
completely moldable but if I don't let
chaos come in they're too hard I can't
move them
I'm not willing to let chaos right so
free will creates chaos because it
directs you out of harmony or in harmony
hmm so you have to have a free will in
order to be a reality creator otherwise
you just be doing what your mom wanted
all along what's the role of good good
and evil there is no such thing no such
thing no there's no such thing
reality is 100% good okay you're
projecting your belief constructs that
you you negativity is a human human kind
of weirdo negativity is 100% generated
by the human mind there's nothing
negative out there there's no evil in
the universe except what we
contextualize it to be some nature
vibrating in harmony is just getting the
in law yeah and then we just
contextualized we solicit trying to
figure out reality in the black and
white state adolescents don't like gray
it's this or it's that let's just agree
on that because they don't want a gray
or it because that gives everything
crazy time now everything's crazy
because we're not agreeing we just need
to agree on something and move forward
so do you agree that laws of
thermodynamics are in place okay yeah
let's just for the argument you know
what I mean it's like you you're the
adolescent is trying to get agreement in
order to feel better about their
position outside validation so free will
is not operating because you're going
for validation it could also be true to
say that if you believe in email then
you still believe there's a victim yeah
because there's a power out there and
rater than me if you are generating it
all and it's all for you to understand
something about your
and it is done out of act of love it's
not because most people identify as some
if you harmed somebody then that's not
okay right but we're trying to say that
there's nobody harming you by yourself
you did it to yourself you created it so
that's why it's people and good is just
separation you just that's how you did
you separated from guys no just
separated two thing and it define what
is good what is bad so I can throw this
over here and I can throw this over here
and I know that I what to do with this
and what it's actually just as soon as I
call somebody go I can't change I know
my gonna change the pedophilia I mean
that's the evil [ __ ] may be the paradigm
we live in is an appropriate you know
the reason that is that's free stuff sex
with boys is because they're just
they're closing their sexuality off
since sexuality is a part of the human
animal the human being and it's actually
the fastest way to enlightenment is
through your sexuality if I inhibit that
in somebody they're going that if I say
you can't be with women and you can't be
they're gonna shame and they're gonna
take it underground and since the only
people around our other boys that are
trying to do this this let's all have
sex with boys this I'll keep it
underneath we don't tell people what's
going on because we need to have sex we
need to grow and you see so it gets
twisted it gets distorted and then of
course everyone calls an evil it's just
a distorted form of love because I'm not
able to express myself more fully
there's only a dark Avenue so the love
has it come through a dark Avenue but
this is one of the to talk about this is
one of the
things that need for people to drop
because for me I come from a family that
has a history of sexual abuse in and to
tell someone especially someone that you
care about to that that it was you
created it you know what I mean like
that's [ __ ] that's nuts right like
how am I gonna tell someone who just
went through rape or molestation or
anything that you created it no they
didn't create it that's the thing they
allowed it
they allowed but your Tia create reality
or you elaborate on them that's only two
ways this machine function but you're
still responsible nobody was because you
allowed it I said I still allow that you
create reality where you allow reality
okay and then what about what about the
role of finding meaning and bringing
gifts you don't find me that's what the
adolescent does I need someone to give
me meaning you find meaning in yourself
and you look for the inflection in
yourself yes so there's an there's an
inherent gift that can be uniquely
expressed into the world and so then
it's about expressing that but it's
about also kind of finding that within
what that right is yes it's not about
finding it externally right yeah finding
it as soon as you do that you've already
done the opposite it's with the machine
in Reverse is that the purpose of this
entire experience of source is for us to
have some sort of a maximization of
conscious experience or creativity no
it's a maximization of significance see
what is reality it's light and matter if
I make something matter so much what's
the thing you tell somebody when they're
all super deep in their [ __ ] you're like
dude you gotta lighten up you got to get
back into the paradox in between the two
things to get movement I all lighten up
now if I'm all light and all airy-fairy
and we mood all the time and I'm not
grounded
did you tell me dude you need to grab
mattering is simply
emotional significance that's what it
takes emotional significance for
something to take form and so you need
to learn how to use your mind to create
emotional significant imaginatively and
then that big thing will come towards
you looks like it's coming towards you
but you're actually manifesting reality
is just mirroring who you are inside you
just get better at that and watch this
thing do it
that's really it in a nutshell it's just
there's lots of processes because if I
really don't know how to forgive it I
don't how to trust people and I don't
got to be intimate I can't make the
machine work very well so I need to
understand forgiveness as a process I
need to understand trust is a process
getting better at I need to understand
how to be loving I have to understand
that it's about me understanding others
understand the reality love the reality
from here and then watch it change it's
like it's a different way to operate
something but it's everybody knows we
need to be more emotional we need to
feel more but not feel more in the same
[ __ ] I've been feeling all along I have
to feel new [ __ ] that I have to come up
with because that's time I sucked the
life out of the past it's just so much
dead and so good it's like how many most
people grow until they just can't
[ __ ] take that [ __ ] anymore
instead of like growing when it's easy
as soon as I recognize that I'm feeling
some limitation let me look at my
beliefs let me change my beliefs let me
change it when it's easy and you have
time because if you don't change it the
spiral gets dense and it gets stuck and
before you know it I got cancer and I've
got to change my job and I got to change
my diet I have to change my way I feel
with my husband maybe even leave them to
heal myself because I wait so long to
respond because I'm not understanding
what reality is reflected to me
Wow yeah Costas reality creation is a
great way to to put this and I think
yeah yeah self authoring is such a
critical way of perceiving the world to
eat full control see full sovereignty
over our beliefs and how they create our
experience in our that create a reality
it's just a gorgeous wave of person I
only came back to share I didn't even
have to be here but I knew that this was
an opportunity for me to see more of my
own love in play again like wow now that
I actually had an opinion and at work
and I saw and I put myself back in
physical reality because I understood
the beliefs I understood what was
outside I was able to put myself back
here consciously it gives me an
experience to share so I can hold a
lineup
no matter what it's like when it's only
opinion you'll get us to a point where
you're scared like wow this is I never
get scared
I don't care [ __ ] what's going on you
know what it mean it's like if somebody
came in here right now with a gun and
just I would just say dude what's going
on I would be like haha I would just be
right here at reality and keep working
it through because I know I could make
all this go away from the inside right
now I have to understand wow I'm really
aggressively mad right now to want to
dominate something like this right I
would woo I would be working so fast
that I would end up fixing the problem
I'm not afraid of any of that anymore
matter of fact I'm enjoying more and
more being in situations where people
see me react from the hip and go WOW
because I'm coming from a different set
it's not like I had to think about I
don't think about how what I'm gonna say
next
I don't think about what I'm gonna talk
about here a little bit just like hey
boys to us that's doing it for me yes we
set function what do we want to feel
like yeah what's the quality that I want
to
- its right it was Grace's idea to talk
about the imagination her and I decided
last night together you know what do we
want to talk about tomorrow I said
because technically here's I mean this
is not a judgment don't take it that way
maybe fly away but I want to say that
but it was like I was like well Alan
hasn't told us anything about the
interview so it's like I realized in
that moment I have to take more
responsibility for the interview because
I want it to go well and I can't expect
somebody that doesn't understand the set
to really know how to engage in the set
but if all of us are there and don't be
a different way for him to relate you'll
see it from a different position than
just listening to Rick Perry Rick Perry
and so we all came to a loving play just
say okay let's just share and I said I'm
gonna try to not talk the whole time I
want you guys an expression I want them
to see you
you are the fruits of my love in a way I
want you guys to go do I'm doing my
reality perfectly I will and I am
stepping out in the world but the more
closer the more beautiful this is the
easier it is for me to take more
responsibility out there because I have
a support system I have people that love
me and I love them and we are growing
together and watching ourselves you know
like just a month ago somebody in our
group $200,000 somebody our group
$400,000 chances and there's a real
realities poppin just being who we are
it's like I only share that because it's
a powerful thing to share not what we're
doing
no it's just it's a powerful part of our
relationship together being real with
each other loving each other like being
honest like
be honest like you know well it's a
spiritual family that's this is a chosen
family
I don't engage my birth family there's
nothing left you know I can't really
let's say if I didn't create the reality
that my mom asked me not to come around
anymore I never would've let them I
would have been always trying to like
make it better make it work better when
I get a new father it was like they
didn't want to play they're like where
Southern Baptist we have a very
fundamental construct we don't know who
the [ __ ] you are you know you're not the
same person we do agree okay I will I
know graciously walk away and it was
such a gift because I realized yeah that
was a lot of energy trying to like get
my family to heal and understand I know
it was like too much yeah damn Wow
so this is it seems as though than
spreading around the sovereign belief
that creates experience it creates a
reality through conscious reality
creators on both YouTube and so you guys
will have we be having more content
coming up you'll also be is it going to
be like both Elizabeth and and you're
taking on additional people that can
come through the platform to work with
the what do you mean like they're going
to be talking but we're gonna be
smoothing the YouTube videos into a
group discussion just like this yeah
interesting we want to do a show similar
to this
this is great so there's gonna be so
there's going to be the different people
that you're working with they're gonna
come on the live set with you guys in oh
we wouldn't even do Collins and some
process it'll be Paul and processes okay
so that's very powerful with Zone C is
how to process with this and other
people are listening to it it's very
powered it is yes because it's real-time
the butterfly effect of of
transformation it's just smooth so
powerful
okay okay so the so the clutched
reallocator will have both come on
they'll have the the show will continue
all the web 72 but then there's also an
interpersonal for those that are maybe
local they can come and do interpersonal
connect with us and we'll connect with
read every whatever we're open to the
form isn't that support it's how we're
feeling about what we're sharing yeah
and one thing I just want to say that
Rick decided to do with all this stuff
was just to share it all yeah you don't
even like that what I would yeah great
let's baby big word let's do this
together but it means I'm gonna put
everything I can out there like water
and so but at the same time I also know
it's very even if you listen to
everything it's like it took me almost
thirty years like to really get good and
understand and in the death experience
and everything where these guys are just
getting the cream of the cake all the
time they I don't teach them everything
I just teach them what they need to know
on their way and they're all thriving
and experience in their life so
beautifully that I just want to be the
resource for them I just want to see
them coming boom boom boom
you know and so what's happening is you
without an intimate relationship that's
built out of the adult like how often do
we get relations when
that's my mom that's my dad or this same
man every time because that's the
adolescent creating those relationships
not the adult because you don't know
what I need what I wanted what to ask
for and not afraid to do it out of the
sake of intimacy I have to be vulnerably
honest to this person right missus
there's a bunch of structure to do this
no yeah I give you examples to two P
both these people came in my life here
because I asked for it
so first list came in my life I was I
wanted to heal with women that was my
intent and I said okay I want a woman to
come into my life to heal with Liz came
out like three weeks later started
shooting with us and working with us
yeah well no I wasn't pretty intimately
and then I asked for I wanted to deal
with my masculine I want a male teacher
that's what I asked for and then it was
like two weeks later Rick was on some
thing I live on Facebook wherever and I
had already heard about him to Liz but
connected with him and he had a program
available to go into and that's how it
all started but it's conscious choice
right yeah yeah and so I'm just opening
to receiving right because when you're
artistic at this and you don't do it
first I love you well I'm just gonna
receive the whole point of getting in a
centered transcendental space is to be
connected to source and then demand to
create a reality with source mmm and you
come out with a new experience not just
get in there and hang out sit there be
oh that's so beautiful actually yeah
yeah not just sit in and just yeah
disconnecting yeah disconnect it's it's
as though it's that second part that's
so critical is the conscious reality
creation with source after denied divine
connection yeah that's beautiful what
are we doing together because the
goddess always says yes anything you
want you want cancer okay you're not
really hurting yourself this is the
illusion to play me God you're here to
play with something that's totally
mutable that you're not hurting yourself
I mean it hurts when in here but I mean
in the big picture you're not hurting
yourself you're here for an experience
that
looks real so I can understand who I am
and watch what I create because really
what people don't get when they're here
you're here in physical on the physical
plane because you are [ __ ] maverick
you are a high-end consciousness
consciousness on the other side doing
something most consciousness is not
going to even bother to do be physical
because you are stepping down the
residents so deep and so low you're so
far from source right now you can't even
remember that you came from there in
order to create something new in order
to really this is my universe when you
die and this is over you don't have a
legacy you didn't help anybody really
didn't do anything except engage in
reality because you now as quantum
physics suggest it depends on the
observer if you remove the observer
there's nothing there anymore when you
remove yourself from the possibility the
physical reality goes back to
possibility just waits for another spark
to mirror itself from you and all of us
are gonna have our own universe it's not
all of sharing you're creating that it's
a consensus you're creating that because
you're trying to make sense out of a
million different parts of myself so
you're making it look like this in order
to navigate it all all of us have our
own universe yes and is shared as well
it's like bubble bath now we're sharing
it because we're [ __ ] when I walk out
the door if you're here we're not
sharing the universe anymore yeah yeah
as I'm saying your souls are playing
with each other so on the form shins
you're not looking at
I did some thievin here's the soul it's
not even super into your relationship
with other people
your soul is only interested when you
are loving the person when you are
intimate now the sophism
because all of this is your soul all of
this and all the lifetimes you can live
and not live that possibly your soil is
ripe dipped in all of them it's just
waiting for one of those things to wake
up so I can focus so when you start
becoming intimate with your entire
reality now that's what always hurts me
yeah because matrice reflection of soul
you start getting filled by beauty this
is your soul fighting when you cry at
the jumper knee this is your soul
weeping for with you when you something
so beautiful you cry your soul is right
next to you right so that's what happens
so if I'm going for something like I
want to connect and make more money
that's a goal if I can intimate with
money my soul will then pay attention
and the soul is the receiving aspect
right so that's where it will start
coming you're loving it and you're doing
it so you're checking out and more so
now you've been in your relationship
with money maybe I have some anger and
resentment because it
growing up and all the different stuff
so I have a negative relationship with
money but once I got intimate with my
reality meaning I'm gonna look at my
reality right now get intimate with it
no matter how bad it looks name I'm
really struggling with money right now
and that's when I engage my soul into it
that's when I actually be able to be
able to change it I understand that
deeper you see your soils crazy all
possibility your soul is outside of
space and time so everything within
physical reality is a reflection of your
soul so this is a lot of information
this lifetime and millions of unlimited
amount of other ones I could be
experiencing so your soul is just like
dreaming waiting for one of those things
to come home the minute that it comes
home it's like oh I'm waking up to
myself so let me engage because right
now it's just a sea of possibility and
since we haven't woke up yet this is the
time that human beings are actually with
you your soul wants to come in more than
ever before because you are in the
position to wake up and so now you're
burning the jungle it's like you're
going to realize that the world is not
working the way you think it's global
warming is not a function of us being
[ __ ] and don't know what the [ __ ]
were doing and judging you of being it's
coming out of the earth testing is the
space we live on if we're gonna make it
quantum leap the earth has to go through
a transition first because we're here
it's birthing the new paradigm for us
when a woman goes into labor her
temperature goes up our hormones go
crazy the earth is going through a shift
whether it's going to be a function of
your emotionality more than a path you
are going to be able to change it
so such a conversation across all these
complex topics flowers conservation
let's do another catch-up we'll do
another session maybe in the next couple
of months towards the winter or later in
the first part of the year because it'll
be good too
they'll be good to see how things have
been synthesizing for you guys and then
also it's been coming for us and see
where we interplay and again yeah the
next conversation because this may be it
was a lot of fun fun thank you everyone
for tuning in and we greatly appreciate
it we'd love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode let us
know what you're thinking do check out
the links in the bio to conscious
reality crater comm also to their
YouTube page check out those links in
the bio and also have more conversations
and your friends families co-workers
people online about conscious reality
creation about the topics that we talked
about in the show manifest that future
that you have within you bring your
gifts forth yeah can I just say those
yes if you are feeling it and you know
you want change and you're resonating
with this then call get on this night
promise you know with every ounce of my
physical illusion I am teaching what's
next
I'm maybe I'm not the only one out there
but I am teaching what's next and I can
help you get out of this paradigm and
I'm ready to do that so it resonates
follow through just follow through with
it and you will find your way yeah yeah
dude this is new yeah yeah but I love
the call to action
and that's such a critical part of this
just take that the initiative of moving
forward it's the new paradigms yeah yeah
um it also support the artists the
entrepreneurs the spiritual leaders the
organizations around the world do you
believe in support conscious reality
create a support simulation our links
are below you can support some paypal
patreon cryptocurrencies all those links
are below also you can design
commercially paid also school they've
built the future everyone manifest those
dreams into the world sound for
conscious reality creator we love them
very much thanks for tuning in and we'll
see you soon peace I was gonna throw the
comments
do it you're like Heather oh it hasn't
ended yet
oh so now you're on the throne they're
all